bonjour à tous et à toutes l'invité de
sark a dit ce matin chantal sac arabe
annie perreault bonjour aux gens vous
êtes directrice du caddie c'est vous
organisez le mois du doc alors avant de
parler du mois du doc et du des films
présentés nous le centre d'action et de
développement d'initiatives culturelles
éducatives le cas dit ce qu'est ce que
c'est exactement alors c'est une
association qui existe depuis une
trentaine d'années mais qui a vu le
département cinéma naître en 2007 donc
voilà on a quand même un certain nombre
d'années qui a à la fois un département
radio associatif avec super radio est un
département cinéma avec ciné woulé
company alors c'est une association axée
éducation à l'image mais éducation aussi
à la radio et on essaie de développer un
certain nombre d'activités tout au long
de l'année et depuis plus de 20 ans au
niveau de toutes ses activités
vulgariser à la fois l'outil la radio et
puis au niveau du cinéma
on a la chance d'être à la fois
formateur mais on fait aussi de la
diffusion puisqu'on un circuit itinérant
le seul de martinique officiellement et
à côté de ça on fait aussi parfois de la
distribution on fait aussi de la
production on est une petite association
mais on essaie de faire les choses bien
c'est l'ancien chocottes doxa alors non
l'association de choquant doc a
développé le mois du doc jusqu'à l'année
dernière
et puis l'année dernière on a repris la
coordination mais on fait pas
essentiellement le roi du dock calciné
rouler c'est à la fois passeur d'image
depuis 20 ans c'est tous les dispositifs
scolaires écoles collèges lycées
apprentis au cinéma c'est les résidences
artistiques en milieu scolaire c'est
aussi le ciné bocage les projections en
plein air du côté de partout on va
peut-être pas citer mans la ville des
trois ilets tous les derniers vendredis
du mois
c'est un certain nombre d'actions
régulière chaque mois c'est aussi le
festival du très court métrage depuis
l'année dernière au moins de juin c'est
le mobile film aussi sur lequel on est
dessus puis le mois du doc au mois de
novembre alors ce qui frappe justement
dans ce mois du doc c
nombre de lieux de projection du nord au
sud ces cases on est en décentralisation
dit localisation c'est le travail que
nous menons c'est dire que sur un
territoire aussi petit que le nôtre il
ya quand même un seul lieu de cinéma que
vous connaissez tous et que je ne
nommerai pas et en fait cette structure
apporter du liant au niveau du cinéma
parce que très tôt on s'est rendu compte
que c'était nécessaire qu'il y ait un
circuit itinérant à l'ansej qui est pas
de tsa en martinique donc jusqu'à 2016
nous étions locaux au cinéma les
auditeurs et spectateurs
ça c'est quoi c'est une taxe spéciale
additionnelle voilà et c'est en fait
c'est la taxe que tout le monde paye sur
les tickets cinéma qui au niveau
national fait quasiment 12% qui en
martinique sera bloqué à 5 % et de
financer aussi des finances et un
système français qui al'avantage de
permettre aux producteurs de faire du
cinéma parce que cette taxe est reversée
au niveau du cnc et tous les gens qui
font du cinéma ça leur permet de faire
de la production donc des gens comme zen
palcy comme lucien jean baptiste se sont
énormément battu pour mettre en place et
à tsa en martinique
d'autant plus que quand le cnc est né la
martinique est encore colonie donc sa
nappe est à appliquer et puis après il
ya eu plein de conflit disent au
juridique est en fait la tsa n'a été
appliquée qu'en 2007 grâce à la tsa une
association comme la nôtre est équipé
avec le cnc puisqu'il y avait des fonds
pour permettre l'équipement faut pas
oublier que dans les années 80 il y
avait plus de vingt salles en martinique
et que le manque de financement le
manque de législation a fait que toutes
ces salles ont disparu c'est vrai que ça
avant il y avait des quasiment chaque
commune kazim avait sa salle il y en
avait plus d'une dizaine à fort de
france même les non seulement sur ce
fort de france et aussi sur celle cher
et toutes les communes avaient une salle
à quasiment oui mais lorsqu'on n'a pas
les moyens de s'équiper lorsqu'on n'a
pas les moyens d'attirer le public dans
ce qu'on a pas les moyens de modifier sa
salle
et justement la tsa pouvait permettre ça
mais comme elle n'était pas appliquée
donc on n'avait pas droit au financement
donc à travers
vos actions vous portez le cinéma au
plus près de la population
alors oui on a un axe complètement rural
puisque la martinique ça reste un
territoire rural et pour nous tous
l'intérêt d'avoir une structure comme la
note qui est inhérente qui en fait
s'adapte aux territoires c'est de
pouvoir développer des actions cinéma
sur toute la martinique donc c'est un
peu dans cette dynamique la con et
puisqu'on est équipé fin 2017 et en fait
aujourd'hui on déploie un peu noël de la
preuve c'est qu'on a senti une brochure
pour un peu expliqué ce qu'on fait parce
que on fait énormément de choses qu'on
n'a pas forcément les moyens de
communiquer dessus
donc on développe des actions notamment
pour les scolaires
donc on va dans des lieux qui sont
capables de nous recevant et là encore
on a des lacunes très peu de villes ont
des espaces adaptés pour que nous
circuits itinérants ont pu s'installer
je rappelle que faire du cinéma c'est un
outil c'est un matériel numérique cinéma
c'est un écran c'est une capacité de
travail et si travaillant dcp tous les
gens qui font du cinéma avec du bourg et
du dvd c'est de l'audiovisuel je crois
que c'est important de le dire parce que
j'entends tout le monde dit oh qui font
des festivals qui font des actions
cinéma et ils sont tous sur des supports
audiovisuels donc il faut faire la
différence parce que nous on s'est
équipé il fallait un budget de 170 mille
euros pour s'équiper et aujourd'hui on
est confronté à une concurrence quasi
déloyale d'ambon pas mal de lieux parce
que les gens font du cinéma à toutes
sauces alors je veux bien comprendre
qu'il ya un manque c'est vrai qu'il ya
un manque d'image c'est vrai qu'il ya un
manque d espace et que tout un chacun a
besoin de développer des actions cinéma
m'ont fait pas du cinéma dans n'importe
quelle condition il ya une législation
on va en voir revenir sur la filière
après parlons d'abord dans du mois du
documentaire il y a dix documentaires
comment s'est effectué le choix alors
sur le mois du doc qui existe depuis une
vingtaine d'années au national le mois
du doc permet en fait c'est développé
par images en bibliothèques au niveau
national ça permet en fait de remettre
en lumière les films les films
documentaires parce que c'est un type de
film que forcément les gens n'aiment pas
je pense que la majeure partie de
d'entre nous préfèrent sans doute les
fictions les choses comme ça le
documentaire c'est si c'est particulier
donc nous ce qu'on a fait c'est que
l'année dernière on avait fait une
tentative en mettant une thématique un
peu très axé santé et cette année on
s'est dit bon on va cibler on va prendre
dix films on va les mettre avec des
thématiques un peu différente pour
toucher tous les publics et voir notre
capacité à faire les gens soient
déplacés sur le documentaire d'où le
choix fait dire qu'on a quand même pris
des choses local on appris des films qui
ont été réalisés en entier qu'on a
démarré par ça on s'est associé à des
associations comme l'a été aussi pour
mettre de la lumière sur eux mais on a
aussi pris des films qui sont sentis un
cinéma qui sont récents donc des films
comme le film de diego maradona qui
n'est pas arrivée en martinique le film
de lourdes parce que bon il faut bien il
ya un public pour ça voilà on a appris
aussi des films axés accès écologie
comme l'intelligence des arbres on en a
pris deux la place d'aidés réalisateur
martiniquais dans ce mois du
documentaire
alors ce qui est dommage c'est qu'on a
on a pris du temps pau choisir deux ou
trois documentaires et que
malheureusement les réalisateurs ne sont
pas si au site
ils sont pas en martinique et qu'on va
se retrouver à présenter des films pike
les réalisateurs mais bon c'est pas
grave
l'intérêt pour nous c'est de montrer du
film d'être à l'écouté du public et de
développer alors quand c'est possible il
ya du débat sur loup durera du débat sur
le film le film qu'on va passer à la
médiathèque du saint-esprit il y aura
aussi du débat entre nous et la mer
chaque fois que c'est possible nous en
tant que circuits itinérants ont créé le
débat parce que tout l'intérêt de faire
du cinéma itinérant c'est aussi d'être
proche de son public
combien de films martiniquais sur la
dizaine environ on va dire 3 on 3 4
parce qu'on a aussi des petits courts
métrages comme métamorphose de nathalie
chi lan cam a été énormément proposé qu'
on propose génèse des bouliac on a passé
deux jouissent en olemps vous l'avez
bien à côté on a aussi entre nous et la
mer qui va passer du côté de la
médiathèque du saint-esprit mardi alors
est ce que nous avons nous ont menti ni
qu'une culture du documentaire une
culture du film culture
du cinéma est ce que pour nous ça
devient vrai une vraie économie alors je
dirais que le cinéma est arrivée en
martinique aussi vite qu'il est arrivé à
paris pour la tout ce qui est projection
35 mais que malheureusement et on vous
dira clairement les choses à nos
politiques n'ont pas su continuer cette
dynamique le cinéma ça fait 20 ans que
je suis dedans je dirais que c'est la
quatrième roue du carrosse une commune
met en place une une projection cinéma
parce qu'il peut pas faire autre chose
et que c'est ce qui va lui coûter le
moins cher et qui va lui donner le moins
de tracas pour une filière porteuse
qu'est-ce qui ça devrait être une
filière porteuse d'autant plus que quand
on regarde ce qui est produit nous
martiniquais on n'est pas si visible que
ça
tout l'intérêt d'avoir un bureau de
tournage en martinique c'est de pouvoir
développer des choses de pouvoir
structurer la filière de permettre à
tous les intermittents toutes les
personnes qui font du cinéma de
travailler ça reste un secteur très
difficile et pourtant on a de nombreux
talents ici on a des gens qui ont un
talent immense et avec qui on pourrait
travailler maintenant la grosse
difficulté c'est que c'est un septième
ans c'est une industrie et que si on n'a
pas les moyens de faire du cinéma on
n'en fait pas
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'il manquait
ce qui ferait valoir exactement et
appelle volonté politique et pourtant le
bureau de tournage a été créé au poivre
à la volonté politique et des rien ne
pas avoir la volonté financière
on dira que c'est ça il faut la volonté
politique plus la volonté financière et
il faut aussi une vraie restructuration
aujourd'hui si on veut mettre en place
un film il faudra structurer la filière
complète mais on obligé de s'adresser à
un producteur dans l'hexagone
s'adressant aux producteurs dans
l'hexagone c'est changer le regard du
film
quelqu'un qui vit dans l'hexagone n'a
pas forcément le même regard comme anti
après il va vouloir faire un film
totalement universel tout l'intérêt pour
nous de faire du long métrage ou de
faire de la série c'est de parler de
nous de parler de nos problématiques et
quand finalement on s'associe avec des
gens d'ailleurs cette problématique là
disparaît donc le ciné menti et est ce
qu'il existe réellement mis à part rue
cases qui parle vraiment de nous
mise à part des gens comme voilà comme
usain palcy qu'on fait des choses avec
ordinaire on peut on peut compter sur
les deux doigts d'une main les films qui
ont été produits et qui nous représente
et c'est ça qui est dommage parce que je
veux bien qu'on parle de la martinique
mais pas qu on nous ridiculisent ou
qu'on raconte n'importe quoi il ya
suffisamment de gens intelligents de
gens formés de gens qui ont du talent
pour qu'on puisse aller au delà de ça
maintenant est ce que c est super engagé
que de vouloir qu'on parle de la
martinique qu'on parle des antiques on
parle de notre histoire qu'on puisse
nous montrer aussi à l'écran parce que
notre jeunesse elle a quoi comme
référent le cinéma ça permet de
développer énormément de choses le
déçoit mais oui il estime de soi
si si demain matin on ne raconte pas
notre patrimoine on ne raconte pas la
vie tu en avais dans quelques années
tout sera formaté notre jeunesse
la preuve aujourd'hui on a des jeunes
qui vous disent clairement qu'ils
parlent pas créole qui ne connaissent
même pas les légumes et les fruits du
pays même les saisons je pense qu'il
faut vraiment revenir sur les
fondamentaux maintenant on demande pas à
nos politiques
on sait que le chômage tout ce qui a
comme souci prioritaire mais au moins de
faire une vraie production martiniquaise
par année est de permettre à toutes les
personnes qui se sont investies de
travail et j'espère que vous serez
entendu madame chantal sac arabe annie
perreault chevaux merci bonne journée à
l'écouté de nos programmes
merci beaucoup
[Musique]